some of you may have noticed that the
david pakman show launched on spotify a
little while ago I think we've been on
Spotify for several months and it's been
really good for us not every show can
just get unspotted I anybody can create
a podcast feed and submit it to iTunes
and if it meets the technical
requirements that iTunes puts in place
you're now on iTunes Spotify is a little
more restrictive and we were part of an
invitation of podcast a group of
podcasts that was invited to be on
Spotify and getting on there has been
really big for us we have a significant
podcast listener ship on Spotify in
addition to the other platforms we're on
like iTunes and iHeartRadio and stitcher
and some of the other ones Spotify has
now made the decision to delete several
episodes of Alex Jones's podcast Alex
Jones is conspiracy podcast it's I don't
know if it's the exact same content that
goes on Alex Jones Infowars web site or
his YouTube channel but there's
certainly a lot of overlap and what he
puts out in audio form and what goes out
in video form part of those some of
those episodes have been deleted by
Spotify and this is part of like a
growing backlash against them and when I
say backlash I don't mean like a
concerted political effort against Alex
Jones I just mean that a number of
different social media and content
distribution platforms have decided that
some of Alex Jones content violates
their Terms of Service
facebook suspended Alex Jones personal
page and removed some of his videos
YouTube removed for videos and Spotify
now has pulled some episodes of Alex
Jones content from their platform and
the reasoning has been pretty similar in
all of these cases and it's been some
version of these episodes violate our
guidelines our Terms of Service in terms
of the content that exists there and of
course Alex Jones fan base immediately
started saying and some on the right
started saying this is an effort to
censor right-wing views these are
violations of free speech and really
going off the deep end with
this stuff the bottom line here is I
hate to break it to you but this really
isn't very controversial we might not
like it we might disagree with these
policies but YouTube has Terms of
Service guidelines the David Pakman show
has had videos demonetised we've had
videos flagged as age restricted that I
didn't necessarily agree should be age
restricted which limits the amount of
money you can make on them we've had
videos removed altogether although not
for content but because of for example
alleged copyright infringement it's not
a political attack on the David Pakman
show it's part of the sort of anti
controversy bias that YouTube has
because of its advertiser relationships
Facebook some of our content has been
flagged on Facebook because we had
b-roll right that video that sometimes
plays while I'm describing the story to
you if that was allegedly too graphic or
exceeded sort of went over the line that
Facebook has set for its community I
don't like it it's just not a huge deal
and I wish the policy were different I
wish I could always monetize every
single video and get you know a hundred
percent of the possible revenue out of
the content we produce as opposed to
some fraction short of a hundred percent
but the framing of this entire thing as
an anti Alex Jones conspiracy is just
totally without evidence and the problem
with Jones's he builds up a narrative of
the globalist are controlling the media
and they're hiding the truth and they
want to censor me or him as Alex Jones
would say then a few of his episodes get
removed and now that becomes evidence
supposedly supporting that conspiracy
theory it's sort of like the if I said
car companies set up brakes to need to
be replaced all the time so that you
have to spend money imagine that I say
that every single day on the show car
companies are running a scam that is
break pads they're running a scam and
after 18 months my brake pads now have
actually worn out and I finally have to
change them and I say look this is proof
that my conspiracy theory it is accurate
I've been saying this for 18 months is
it really or is it
just that after 18 months at some point
you got to replace your brake pads and
Spotify and YouTube and Facebook have no
obligation to host Alex Jones content if
he wants to run his own servers he can
put whatever the hell he wants on those
servers and there won't be anybody there
who could even possibly censor him
assuming the content isn't illegal but
that would be him saying well I want a
forgo the audience that YouTube brings
or the audience that Facebook brings and
put the content on my own server
the real concern here is not a few
episodes getting removed
it's that Alex Jones and Trump and
others are all participating in what I
call the degradation of political
discourse the types of conversations and
this is why I've talked about we will
sometimes in a tongue-in-cheek away use
the word cuck but it's really to kind of
make fun of the people that use it and
I've said I I don't know if that's a
good idea because even using the term
sarcastically suggests that it might
even be a valid term in political
discourse Jones and Trump and these
others have either under the name of
telling it like it is or telling a truth
that nobody else is willing to or
whatever it fuels this reduction of
politics to bottom-feeding sort of
lowest-common-denominator debate and
conspiracy theories and not having to
defend what you say with any kind of
facts that's what's really dangerous and
the entire sort of milieu that considers
this even remotely reasonable debate
what Alex Jones does the comet ping-pong
thing which I guess he's backed off of
now at this point whether you believe
eight of ten facts or six of ten
assertions or whatever about comet
ping-pong the idea that that entire
story even qualifies as a legitimate
debate is part of the problem that needs
to be addressed and I actually don't
know how so if I'm wrong if if the
removal of a few episodes of Alex Jones
podcast from from Spotify is actually
the problem that the Wright says it is
let me know and explain to me
specifically why I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break
coming to you from New Orleans Louisiana
where
is extraordinarily hot and humid we've
got a great program planned for you
today
today's episode is made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman I've
spoken about the unfair and unfortunate
stigma that there can be around therapy
there shouldn't be and better help makes
things even easier for you if you've
been thinking about getting involved and
working with a therapist you get access
to fully licensed experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer all you have to
do is go to better help calm slash
Pakman you fill out a questionnaire they
match you with a counselor that'll work
best for you you can ask if you want
that your therapist not be religious if
that is important to you and at any
point if you think your therapist is not
a good fit you can switch and work with
somebody else it's less expensive than
seeing a counselor in person but better
help also gives you unlimited access to
your counsel you can talk to them every
day if you want you will not get that
with an in-person therapist so go to
better help calm slash Pakman so easy to
sign up and get started we've put a link
in the video description if you're
watching on YouTube check it out better
help calm slash PA que ma N